- You got to me, right?
You've got a social
following, right?
You DM me,
I'm taking random ones.
Some people have six followers,
some people have 250,000
followers and here we are.
We're talking and you can
reach out to other people.
You should reach out to people
that are making content that
fits the tone of your music,
hit them up and
see if they'll use
your music in their content.
Some guy makes a
video that gets,
if Casey Neistat makes a
video and uses your song in it,
that can break you out.
So yeah, distribution's changed.
Good Charlotte is famous
because of Madden football,
a video game.
That's just true and
right now in a year,
I'm gonna put a song in one of
my videos and that artist will
become famous off the fact that
I have a huge base
and it gets passed on.
And by the way, there's tens of
thousands of people that have
bigger audiences than
me in different genres.
Playing on Twitch,
playing on YouTube,
playing on Instagram
that you need to get,
so make great fucking music.
Make it fucking often and
find a ton of people that have
audiences to distribute it.
The end.
And never stop until it happens.
(light music)